[Music]
in modern solutions news submitted by
put me in coach
eleven thousand people illegally watched
the ksi versus Logan Paul fight a
reflection of the guises glass in their
in the reflection of a guy's glasses
what genius
wait cuz that's like a not a great
viewing experience it's not but if you
really want to watch something you know
Oh unless the guy streaming it just like
had the reflection had a glasses I don't
know it got worse so is it because
people watch bootleg you know like
movies where they can record things like
this there's guys standing of walking
around people are still down to watch
that so I'm like do they still do those
they do if you go like Santiago you're
still selling DVDs really Oh EDD yeah so
okay it's I love applause I anyone watch
it yeah I missed it watch it case I wish
I heard it was a good fight it was
actually it was [ __ ] man wasn't
there like a referee call that life yeah
wait yeah are they fighting with no head
gear it's a pro fights a potent they got
licensed oh yeah everyone that opened
for them was all-pro boxers what's crazy
there's two title fights that are the
undercard just imagine like Conor
McGregor vs. khabib and then it's [ __ ]
Logan Paul again yeah it's it's crazy
yeah so this guy holy and like the
regulations and stuff for him to
livestream the fight so people are up to
11,000 people at one point where we're
tuning into this guy's life that's smart
didn't get taken down cuz he wasn't
technically here we go yeah he wasn't
directly streaming it from whatever
whoever device he was watching this from
but he was able to stream it from the
reflection of his glasses and so people
were even giving giving him pointers
like dude tilt your head down or he
should have worn those mirror glasses
true Oh straight up like a pop star
yeah I've been like too much much yeah -
so he titled this thing like reacting to
the chaos exo's oh yeah so people are
like he's he's a legend a living legend
huh it was surprisingly a good fight
yeah I could clearly tell they trained
their [ __ ] asses off and I never I
didn't really watch the first fight but
I was really impressed with ksi and like
I think he took it more seriously just
based off it sure I could tell you
outbox Logan Logan is a much bigger
stronger guy so if his hits hurt more
but uh just to see like I think the part
that I admire the most is there's these
two youtubers with like 20 million
subscribers in the beginning when I
viewed it as oh this is just some like
novelty gimmick whatever to see them as
businessmen be able to leverage their
following into another industry and
immediately be at the top I'm like
that's the most genius business move
I've ever [ __ ] seen that [ __ ] and take
it seriously and take it because each
one of them made 5 million damn Wow
so before I was like I'll never [ __ ]
final never do this yeah I got more
holes I actually be like fighting is
sacred to me but I might if someone pays
you oh my god you could buy my morals
my morals but for 5 million at 1 million
1 billion 4 million two months fight
path my house we bid on it on eBay I
mean you've been on your morals idea
like years ago bringing youtubers
together and [ __ ] fights journalize
we just never acted on and no one knows
we are that's true it's different when
you have 20 million followers in case I
fight someone else I remember doing
Dickie in here is like he did a boxing
match to some other guy yeah he bought
slogan before last years before that
really yeah oh yeah you fought some of
the first fight it was ksi and another
white guy yeah forgot his name he hates
white people huh mm-hmm
and then the next one was with Logan so
this is the second time yeah the first
one was like I think it draw yeah and
then no remember that and everyone was
like oh it's [ __ ] red
that one that one it didn't look like
they took it seriously you know it's
just it almost sound like so much
[ __ ] money on his oh yeah give me so
much [ __ ] money
this one they look like they're really
trained and it's not the staple center
which is it's like it's one of the
biggest venues in the nation and I'm
like how they're doing this that another
one yes I use the same nutritionist as a
Conor McGregor yeah I think next um Jake
Paul
Logan Paul's brother's supposed to have
a fight with someone too brother
he wants to fight ksi wait no what Jake
wants if I could listen was there Jay
Paul Jay Jay Jay Paul yeah oh that was
yeah
they opened for Jay Paul and IG opened
for Logan Paul and chaos I've it's cute
we should have like they should have do
MMA next time they should I would pay to
see that I should do a boxing match
I don't watch anybody I love people
fighting who do you be done fighters
fighting I'll fight anybody for the
right non money my morals can be bought
like and he wants me to fight any time
any time there's anything he's like you
should [ __ ] watch oh do you remember
that MTV show Celebrity Deathmatch yeah
nation celebrity that [ __ ] was fun
because it was like people you know
Creed fighting [ __ ] limp their spine
what was this before my time yes that's
really sad no but that was pretty fun
and then they would go like extreme to
where I'm like how the [ __ ] to even
think of in than to create it I clean we
should I remember being a kid and being
like how do you even think of this [ __ ]
as Austin Sooners would you guys ever do
like a fight like this oh hell no I
don't like boxing
I don't like violence I don't like blood
oh yeah that's not fresh maybe a rap
battle for D yeah I would do a rep
that's a roast battle I would do a roast
insult battle yeah Stephen I tried to do
that for a video but he doesn't want to
roast me too hard and then I go too hard
on him so then I just look like an
[ __ ] can't do it what couples
yeah kind of do it with strangers that's
true that's true
it was strangers and I have like no
connection at all I could easily this
this fight said a lot of people off like
I think that they want to keep doing
this now I think that it is like that I
think youtubers boxing yeah I think like
the President or the VP of the zone
which is the app where they screen it on
he came out and he was talking about
like because people that a lot of people
are like isn't this kind of desecrating
I'm boxing like uses people there's
boxing's been desert like there's
there's pipelines to to get to a certain
point and you have to pay your dues and
you have to prove yourself and then now
you're just kind of finding these two
clowns and you're just throwing him into
the boxing world and he didn't view it
like that what he was viewing it is
boxing is here and now I get to expose
it to a brand new audience so now you
have millions of buys from people that
are just on YouTube and I'm like man a
lot of these business people think UFC
and MMA have like kind of taking
boxing's like home away yeah for the
olden Paul and cares had to come in and
kind of give the youth back into boxing
and adding their statement boxing yeah
even with the Jorge Mass with all Nate
Diaz UFC fight they the Canelo which is
like one of the biggest names in boxing
right now I thought he was Irish
the Canelo fight they waited until the
UFC was over to start the fight so I
think for sure they feel threatened by
the UFC like the whole box I heard a lot
of boxing fans left too because of all
the corruption in the [ __ ] up calls as
of late that that's been going on they
feel that there's a lot of unfair things
going on where the sports integrity has
kind of like gone is in general or just
this fight as of late as of recently
there's well there's a huge amount of
politics so in the Jorge mats with all
Nate Diaz fine with you I saw this but
jaurim as but I'll hit Nate Diaz with
the cut right and he was like bleeding
over here and it doesn't look like a
really bad cut but nobody threw the
fight but though what the ref had to
have to cut it and then so I know
Jorge mats with all strength and
conditioning coach so I media texted him
on my
like Congrats on the whatever and I'm
like but I know Nate Diaz is a warrior
and he usually really brings it around
four and five how did you feel about the
stoppage and he goes honestly I wanted
to see them to go 5th round but because
they just got the UFC into New York New
York is still very sensitive about the
way cuts and injuries look so they have
to play politics purse taper nation like
right now in France
MMA is not even legal there yet so
they're gonna be legal in a year
so the first so like if they do hold
that here you have the event in France
you're gonna believe like the minute
someone gets clipped and they're kind of
Wahb doing it they're gonna stop it
right away it poses like you you're
dealing with one's life you know it's
like rather be safe than sorry because
you wouldn't want like a big event to
suddenly have someone dying to do boxers
die this year what yeah [ __ ] I like
during the fighter after the fight
shortly after but they it's directly
related to the file a trauma yeah okay
he wants to see someone die in the rain
accidentally not like I want them to
choke on the mouthpiece or something
like it was just like it's it's just a
it's just aa hazard job like they tied
the gloves I can't feel my hands like
that not a freak accident but like
because like they actually come hurt
wait what's happening you're digging a
hole way too tall we try to help him out
he goes get out of here of watching MMA
right like you're watching the chance of
death that's what's entertaining that
why you like gladiator is that way likes
articulate
not for me it's not it's me seeing like
like the [ __ ] well you're living okay
so you're living blind if you don't
think that this is a warrior sport and
people have it I think it's a warrior
sport for sure yeah but you have the
chance of dying that's the truth
that's what's so Wow about it is that
two people are going full force and they
don't die but but what we like is that
they don't die yeah exactly right
exactly that's most people spot it's
that's the why about it when you jump
you when you bungee jump you go WOW
Selene you yeah yeah you go wow they
didn't die whoa yeah exactly I want that
moment but you want them to actually
right not all the time obviously not all
this to be there for the one time that
happened just once every month or so
yeah it makes me feel like special what
are the odd right why don't you just try
to wish to win the lottery that's like
an extra extra extra spurt that - it
goes positive - but it's not always I
mean it's a spectacle right like how
mental often do you get to do what I'm
doing twice a year you made her nervous
not the conversation listen she's in
trouble she feels like she's in trouble
blasphemy right what's wrong I'm just
thinking the truth go to the ICU you and
it really because I think that's a part
that's a high-probability so it's not a
special it's not special
yeah well it's like if you're in like a
martial arts or anything does you know
you do it I've done it too it's just
like it's like appreciating the human
skill set of survival and also the the
like the dedication on how like life
like threatening moves can be avoided
and also like you know usually with
human power like one hit you can't hit
some interview and when you interview
both fighters they will always go I want
to beat the living [ __ ] out of me go do
you want to kill them like no those
skills don't say no like you're crazy
why don't you just play double O seven
on slappers only and then have your
simple good side I mean I don't want
them to die obviously
[Music]